justin fields throwing out a ceremonial
first pitch first of all he's styling
coming off yesterday when he threw for a
touchdown he rushed for a touchdown and
then he had some cutting action
and those are the rookies the bare
rookies behind him and there is some
huge fellows there a 9-8 record lucas
giolito brings into this game with the
3.81 earned run average opponents
batting 222 on the season against lucas
so a little trouble here in the first
gallow homer twice last night
here's the pitch
fall strike three a slider
painted on the inside corner
giancarlo stanton he's playing left
the 2-2 swinging miss
on the slider
he had to work very hard but he doesn't
give up a run he didn't give up a hit in
fact two walks two left
after a half yankees nothing left hander
nester cortez toes the rubber for the
yankees with an 0-1 record and a 270
earned run average in limited time this
year and it's in the righty-hitting
shortstop and the pitch is lined right
back to cortez who made the catch how do
y'all like that
they hit a bullet
head high and cortez caught it thank
goodness and there's one away
and a burnt by hernandez
and again oh what a play by o'dore
a really good bun by hernandez and our
door fired and got him two away
and that will bring up andrew vaughan
there's the 2-2
swung on and grounded back to cortez
stamps it throws to first and the inning
is over and that will bring up rugi odor
202 the lefty swinging odor
annie it's a long drive to right center
it is high it is far that is gone a
two-run home run for rookie odor
one of those who has stepped in
brilliantly for ashela and torres
and so a two-run blast the yankees have
a two-nothing lead
odor and the yanks take a two-nothing
lead top of the second
so two zip yanks here's the catcher
higashiyoka
oh two swing minimus strike three on a
slider
punch out number three
for giolito
now wade the shortstop lucas is 2-2
and that is a wave and a miss and a
sword and another strikeout on the
slider for giolito here's gardner with
le mayhew at first and two men out
that's a base hit down the right field
line chasing it down as hernandez going
to third is lamia and going to second is
gardner the throw gets away here comes
lemayo and he will score as the yankees
now lead three nothing yanks up a three
nothing leader is judge the o2 to judge
muscled in the air out towards shallow
center but it's going to be caught on
the back pedal
by hernandez
the yankees score three times
moncada at 250
he has 10 homers and 49 rpm
here's the 2-2
and it is cut on and missed so moncada
strikes out one away
now here's the rookie catcher
sevi zavala now the one two
is cut animus to break the ball
and they've got two more on for odor who
banged a two run homer here's the pitch
swing and a miss strike three on a
change up
out number two and it brings up
higashiyoka
giolito and zavala on the same page and
ready for a 2-2
call strike three
fastball on the outside corner
lucas has six strikeouts so now first
and third two out and here is andrew
vaughn
first and third chew out pitch swung on
and hit up the middle grab by wade
throws to second for the force and the
yankees get out of the inning without
giving up a run
joe vaughn
grounds into the 6-4 force no runs one
hit and two left
now now the end of three innings of play
three nothing yet
tyler wade a strikeout victim in the
second
wave and a miss from tyler wade who
strikes out on giolito's change up 7k to
begin the fourth
so gardner at second judge at first in
the battered joey gallow
one two swinging a miss strike three
might be the final pitch thrown by lucas
eight strikeouts through four
but at 101 pitches on the day
he's talking to himself as he walks off
the mound midway in the fourth
this is luis robert a right-hand hitter
o2
that's a strike fastball outside corner
robert caught looking
so chew down that will bring up the
catcher right hand hitting sevi zavala
one and two on zavala tim anderson's on
deck pitch is caught on and miss struck
him out
and now they've got to deal with wade
first and third two gone the pitch is
popped up
shallow left center anderson looking for
help he'll get it from jimenez who comes
in
and makes the catch
the yankees strand a couple each team
has left runners on base in every half
inning
now bree one for one with a walk now the
2-2
is strike three called he came sidearm
and threw a fastball down and in
a man of a lot of different pitches
so a brave strikes out
no runs one hit and no one left at the
end of five three-nothing yanks
bring up joey gallo
the 3-2 to gallow
he struck him up
check swing on a curve he could not hold
first strikeout for ruiz the yankees
strand judge at second base
and the sox bat and the bottom of the
sixth
trailing the yankees three-nothing eloy
jimenez is the lead off at a big strong
right-hand hitter
and cortes deals
cut on him this struck him out on a low
breaking ball andrew vaughan over two
[Applause]
drills this one the left field and the
sucks are on the board
here they come in the sixth inning
well it's nice to have something happen
and erupt these fans with uh some kind
of noise home run number 14 rbi number
38 and it cuts the lead to two
now two way
and here is luis roberts now cortez will
deal one two
and the pitch is strike three came
sidearm and nailed the outside corner
just like he struck out abreu last in it
well nestor court does a great job
he gives up one run
on one hit
and at the end of six innings of play
the yankees three the white sox won so
it'll be gallow
the left-handed batter
who is one for four
a bunch single and three strikeouts
one two pitch he went for strike three
nice work by aaron bummer and ending in
two-thirds of scoreless pitching
and we go to the bottom of the eight it
is the yankees three the white sox won
now here is jimenez
1-2
[Applause]
strike three
and jimenez jumps up in frustration and
he's almost getting thrown out but
esther brooks held himself back
as ximena's down on strikes
and they have thrown out tony larusso
luke voigt is two for four
and the bit swung on and hit in the air
to deep left it is high it is far it is
gone
it's a two run home run oh that void is
a droid he blasts a two run home run to
left field to give the yankees a four
four-run lead
voight
hits one to detroit and the yankees take
a 5-1 lead and here's lehu
man at second with two outs a 2-0 hit in
the air out in the deep center tracking
is robert and he'll run it down on the
warning track he made it look easy it
was not
zach collins the batter
and the 3-2 to collins hit in the air
out into deep right center
that ball
is up the wall
monkott is going to score
robert will be held at third
it's a double for collins
it's five to two still only one out and
it'll bring up ta
peralta sets here it comes uh bouncer
toward the first baseman that's le
mayhew flip to the bag say
anderson beat the throw to the pitcher
peralta robert scores
it's five to three and they're at first
and third with still just one out
so two on and one out and hernandez is
the winning run
saves arm a switch into batting right
and the first pitch is hit on the ground
to second step on second throw to first
it is a double play
ball game over yankees win the
yankees
win